someone was murdered across the street
from my house yeah that was because I
was gonna ask you I heard you murdered
your neighbor one time but it wasn't me
I talked about it on our podcast the
podcast I do with them and then the
headline was Adam DeVine and wife
witnessed murder and I'm like that's not
what happened I don't want any
psychopath out there being like they
witnessed it
um so yeah we did not see it if the the
killer watches this what does that do to
your property value are you worried
about that does it go up my wife was
like we have to sell the house today and
I'm like
we'll wait it out yeah I'm like this is
the Hollywood Hills man people people
are getting shot people come and go yeah
yeah if anything in the Hollywood Hills
that might bump up the value yeah that's
right